ladies and gentlemen if you're into
crypto you like shilling it you like
saying bitcoin to the moon you might
want to pay attention because new
actions for the department of justice
could mean you could be going to jail
for a very long time if you're not
careful
just like john mcafee here he said i'm
john
mcafee world's leading security expert
if i don't want to be
found i will not be found this is before
he got arrested
and now indicted for cryptocurrency
fraud ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar study
i'm your host coffee zilla the internet
detective and today we're talking about
the new rules of the road
um these were always the rules but now
they're starting to get
enforced obviously and
yeah it's it's gonna be an interesting
time so
let's give a little context right i
think everyone knows who john mcafee is
he's an outspoken
sort of outlaw of the internet created
the mcafee
anti-virus but then kind of just lived
his crazy life
if you want to know more about that and
i encourage you it's fascinating go
check out my buddy okie's weird stories
he has
the best like documentary series he's
got a great one on
uh john mcafee it's fascinating you
learn about you know accusations of
neighbors that john mcafee may or may
not have killed i mean
the man lives the craziest life which is
kind of made him into a bit of an
anti-hero it's a bit
easy to root for him because he's so
kind of on the one hand
eccentric on the other hand kind of a
way
self-aware of his distastefulness and
his sort of
criminality but just like scarface or al
capone
was never indicted for you know his his
worst crimes but instead indicted for
tax evasion
in the same way it looks like john
mcafee's going down for the same stuff
for all the things that he's done and
been a part of you would have thought he
would have gone to jail probably a long
time ago
and indeed he's been in hiding for a
very long time but instead it looks like
crypto
and taxes are gonna be what brings him
down so before we get into the whole
cryptocurrency fraud scheme let's just
talk about who john mcafee is as a guy
so this was a thread from 2017 where it
says
so one bitcoin to 500k within three
years
and john mcafee is the type of guy that
would respond if not i will
he eat my dick until
national television that's the kind of
man john mcafee
but moving on to the more serious
allegations john mcafee is accused
of promoting coins altcoins specifically
uh to his twitter followers in exchange
for payment
and not disclosing it and these are
things people need to pay attention to
i've seen a lot of crypto youtubers do
this
they will take payment and coins and
then not ever disclose that they've
taken payment
hey you might go to jail for very long
time john mcafee stands to go to jail
for
60 years so how do you get himself in
that much trouble well he sent out this
tweet
around the same time he was promising
you know the three-year the three-year
bullish bet
over there he was saying each day i will
talk about a unique
altcoin most of the 2000 coins are trash
or scams i've read every white paper the
few i'm connected to i will tell you the
rest i have
no position in these coins will change
the world you can support that change
well at the same time he starts
promoting a bunch of coins and instead
of disclosing what he's interested in or
he has a position
he actually does the opposite according
to the complaint they scalped at least
11 altcoins during the period from 2017
on through early 2018 and these all
coins were electroneum burst coin did
you buy red coin
you get the idea dogecoin is one of them
but basically the reason he is in
trouble
is not because he promoted them but
because he didn't disclose
that he was invested in them or he was
getting a kickback which means for you
guys at home if you're talking about
cryptocurrency with your friends it's
fine talk about it as much as you want
but if you have a public platform
and you're gonna promote these coins and
you're getting paid for it
if you don't disclose it you run serious
risk of uh
yeah getting basically getting indicted
for it which makes john mcafee's twitter
claims
that him and elon musk are the same
because both of them promoted doge
it makes it kind of pointless because
the reason elon musk
presumably promoted doge was as a meme
the reason john mcafee seems to have
promoted it
was because he was getting paid he also
says we were paid in the same coins that
crashed
the sec allegations are overblown but
that's what a pump and dump
is you get paid in it you sell it off to
the people who buy it underneath you
and then they get left holding the back
john mcafee continues that even after it
crashed i held every coin allocated to
me i never sold a single coin
i believed in the company to the very
end he's talking about dokademik
but all it takes is proving that really
he didn't disclose that he paid for
these coins that he was pumping
and therefore misleading his followers
into risky investments for
this case to really stick i mean come on
the only thing from here is whether he's
gonna be in a
spanish jail cell or an english jail
cell i believe he's
arrested in spain right now but uh the
us is trying to extradite him to america
so this is a big lesson number one
even if you're a leading security expert
and you don't want to be found
you will not be found the long arm of
the law probably will find you
if they want to find you when you get
cocky like this and say if they really
wanted you'd be caught in a fortnight
and you start to brag
about how secure you are chances are
you're going down
very soon as for my own personal opinion
of john mcafee i think if he lives up
to his former promise i think all the
charges should be immediately dropped
i don't think they will be uh but i
think you know we should at least offer
him the opportunity to fulfill his into
the bargain here and even if you think
john mcafee is innocent and
shouldn't be uh you know indicted on any
charges i think
this tweet kind of sums it all up john
mcafee says my life has been devoted to
my life
my family's my loves my ambitions
generosity's fears and
desires my apparent selflessness helping
others was still about me
yeah i mean that's sort of the entire
cryptocurrency allegation right you
said you were helping others by helping
them sift through cryptocurrencies
in reality you were enriching yourself
which is
fraud and if you get convicted of these
allegations
he will probably be going to jail and
basically and
rot there until he is dead that's the
cold hard fact and i think it's a lesson
to any would-be crypto pumper
or any investment pumper at all because
there's so much of it going on guys you
have to be so careful with your money
you never know
who is your best interest at heart or
who's taking money on the side um so
please be careful and if you're a crypto
guy please don't
send out investment advice if you're
getting paid behind the scenes because
there's a very real chance that you
could end up behind bars
anyways that's it thanks for watching go
check out my buddy oaky's weird stories
and i will see you guys
next time
wake up and smell the coffee